ça y est le chantier de reconstruction
du forum de coignières est lancé après
six mois de démolition les travaux ont
été inaugurés ce lundi avec une
tradition aux fumées de macadam le gigot
bitume lamballe dans de
l'aluminium croisé dizaines de couches
10 11 12 ça vous tente pas et apprendre
des papiers kraft au toit
ceux ci sont nés dans
la zone laissé à l'abandon après le
départ de castorama en 2009 n'avaient
toujours pas trouvé de repreneur c'est
désormais chose faite décathlon flybaboo
et darty devraient se partager les
quatorze mille mètres carrés et ouvrir
leurs portes d'ici le mois de septembre
nouvelle enseigne mais aussi nouveau
bâtiment seul reste la charpente et le
dallage
un changement est total puisque les
bâtiments avait 25 ans on va un peu plus
de 25 ans ici et donc on veut vraiment
une architecture nouvelle le programme
va faire l'objet d'une certification
breeam nos certifications
environnementales et on va ramener
encore une fois beaucoup de beaucoup de
fraîcheur et beaucoup de renouveau ici
un bâtiment remis aux normes
environnementales donc puisque le
chantier comprend la plantation d'arbres
ou encore un bassin de stockage des eaux
pluviales mais le nouveau forum se sont
aussi de nouveaux emplois pour
coignières et ses alentours dans le cas
de la cellule emploi mise en place à la
mairie eh bien on va participer nos
ports recrutement meerhof on va tout
mettre à la disposition des enseignes
pour que le recrutement je le fasse dans
des locaux mis à disposition par la
mairie le constructeur lui mis sur un
minimum de 130 emplois pour cet
investissement total de 20 millions
d'euros
là